und eigentlich das passt auch weil eigentlich
wollte ich hier ich wollte eine katzennummer
machen super Kätzchen weil funktioniert ja
auch im Internet immer Kätzchen haben ist
das meist geklickte über Kätzchen weil
die sind ja Gäste sind ja immer so süß
mit dem großen Augen und im Möhrchen so
die sind so die sind so süß da musst du manchmal
das Gefühl du willst immer so die willst du so
richtig knuddeln oh so eigentlich kannte also
nicht böse gemeint das ist also ich habe mich
da auch mit mir befasst weil ähm nein ähm und
zwar Wissenschaftler haben das erforscht und
zwar man nennt das cute overload das ist so ja
es gibt also es war die haben die ganze und dann
haben Sie wahrscheinlich das ist gut overload
also so eine Art niedlichkeits-übersetzung das
gibt's tatsächlich weil die Katzen die und dann
muss er ja weil wir versachlichen da Dinge und
zwar Reinheit und Unschuld das sehen wir in
diesen Katzen und deshalb kommt das bei uns
an und das ist sehr interessant weil die haben da
festgestellt dass Katzen ähnlich wie Zucker wirken
also ist die gleichen Region also im Zucker ist
ja in hohen Dosen ähnlich wie LSD also man könnte
sagen Kätzchen sind im Grunde genommen so dass
LSD das Tier Kalender und aber das ist die Katzen
immer die will ich gar nicht erzählen ähm mir ging
es um was anderes wir haben Urlaub gemacht das
wollte ich erzählen und das war wirklich also wir
sind dieses Jahr mit Wohnmobil sind Gefahren sehr
hier sind wir hier Deutschland Schweiz bisschen
Geld wegbringen dann sind wir Frankreich Spanien
Andorra noch mehr Geld wegbringen und dann sind
wir wieder durch und dann sind wir irgendwann
vom Frankreich Schweiz und dann wieder nach
Deutschland und das war wirklich also 500
Meter also der Urlaub war toll also die ganze
Autofahrerei kein Problem dann fährst du so
120 130 total steigst aus dem Auto aus wie acht
Stunden Schlaf ist wirklich toll und aber wir
kommen über die Grenze nach Deutschland nach 500
Metern hatte ich mir den ersten Geschwindigkeits
Nazi hinter mir bitte so Blinker links liegt
Hupe Kofferraum auf Radio laut der hat wirklich
der hat mit dem Emblem hat er mir die Stoßstange
poliert ich konnte nicht rechts rüber weil da war
auch ein Auto und dann und er sagt also Mister
Ruhe in seinem Geduld mobil und irgendwann wurde
ihm zu bunt und dann ist der wirklich links
neben mir also zwischen Leitplanke und unserem
Auto hat er sich so da entlang geschmückt meine
Tochter hinter nur bis jetzt nicht habe ich nur
gesagt und ähm also wie gesagt eigentlich die
Katzen Nummer aber ich will was anderes sagen
und das geht jetzt mir so an die die Vertreter
und und Außendienstler so an die key-accounter
da draußen das geht im Grunde genommen geht es an
diese Tankkarten bewaffneten dienstwagenhase ja
an diese Drängler und Provokateure an diese
rücksichtslosen rechts Überholer ja die die
Mittelfinger besser verstehen als ihren eigenen
Job das geht an diese Narzissten und Egomanen an
diese Schlips [__] und die billigend in Kauf
nehmen dass ich irgendein junge Familie gegeben
hat totfährt und den möchte ich eine Sache sagen
Fahrt euch tot und das ist kein Witz nein nein
wahnsinn das ist mir geht das nimmt eure Mercedes
BMWs Porsche oder wie sonst diese gelisteten Luxus
Pimmel heißen sucht euch irgendeine Allee ein
schönes Bäumchen und wickelt euch mit eurer
Karre da drum auf dass er keine Hydraulikschere
da mehr rausschneidet kein Airbag euch retten tut
uns eingefallen Fahrt euch tot und hört auf
uns zu gefährden ihr Arschlöcher [Applaus]
wussten sie in der Schweiz darf
man in der Schweiz darf man seine
Haustiere Essen ich glaube Kätzchen schminken süß
da war schon verdammt witzig aber wissen was
es kommt noch viel viel anderes witziges Zeug
wenn Sie diesen Kanal abonnieren ich würde
es machen machen sie es hier drücken oder da